[Music]
[Applause]
we segue into Albert Breer the Monday
Morning Quarterback who joins us on the
program so what do you make of that
could you see a day where Robert Craft
fires Bill bellich well first of all let
me just tell you that you're uh you're
speaking to a man whose wife just bought
a 12 foot skeleton to put on our front
line
so how much
skeleton cost oh no it was so there
there's this like little um cuoac like a
a couple a couple uh couple blocks down
or a couple uh a couple driveways down
from our house and every year on
Halloween they did the coolest display
it's like three or four people that live
on it and they did the UN most
unbelievable display well the couple
that organizes it is getting older and
so they decided this was going to be the
year they'd stop doing it so they have
like a big yard sale of all their
Halloween stuff so sure enough my wife
goes in there and she comes out with an
old school TV with like a blood
handprint on it that only plays
Poltergeist right um a big trick-or
treat sign and then this 12 foot
skeleton which of course I was
responsible for carrying down the street
probably great yeah um I like it yeah so
uh I I told her I'm like if this keeps
up you're going to probably try to turn
me into Clark Clark gwal for Christmas
so um yeah you know and I'll take the
hard left turn now toich Che job status
um you know I I I I felt like you know
Robert Craft has this term elegant
solution or elegant conclusion and you
know I I think um he would prefer that
with Bill like I think he would prefer
that it end in a way where he's able to
give Bill his breast r and send him off
into the
sunset and you know I I don't think Bill
wants to be done coaching after this
year and so I think you know what I've
felt like for a while now is what would
hasten his departure wouldn't be just a
Flatout firing it would be a your
football operation is messed up we need
to restructure we're going to
restructure when you leave anyway
because no coach gets that much power so
instead of doing after you leave we're
going to do it now and we're going to
bring in a Personnel man and that
Personnel man is going to report to me
not to you um you're still going to
report to me but we're going to set this
up differently um because we don't feel
like you've done a good enough job
putting Talent on the roster over the
last five years and then it might be up
to bill you know and in that case it
would be do you want to be part of this
or not and ironically enough like that's
what hastened the departure of Bill par
ourselves if you remember they took
Personnel power away from him in 1996
there was the whole Terry Glenn thing
and then he walked in 97 and so would
Bill have an appetite for coming back
under a different structure with a
general manager who doesn't answer to
him interesting I felt like all along
like that was the more likely conclusion
if this season didn't go right but I
didn't foresee them losing by 30 two
weeks in a row so you know I think
everything might be on the table now gut
feeling how does this end
my gut feeling is they're not good
enough this year that the roster just
flat out not good enough you know you
know what the best way to illustrate it
is Dan look at the roster tell me what
player you can say he gonna be there
five years from
now one player Christian
Gonzalez who's been there for 10 minutes
yeah right like I mean that's the sort
of disrepair the roster is in right now
and
um you know so I I I like I don't think
they're good enough um I think that this
is probably at best a six or seven win
team I don't think that's going to be
good enough for Robert Craft and I think
they're going to be at a Crossroads at
the end of the year and I don't think if
you know if things play out that way if
it's six or seven wins I don't think
Robert Craft is going to be satisfied to
run it back the same way it is now in
2024 and I think that would lead to
difficult conversations and I mean it's
certainly possible the conclusion could
be that bill bich is no longer the coach
in
2024 and um you know it's it's almost
hard to Envision that scenario it would
have been you know if you had said that
before the year or a couple years ago
certainly but that's where the roster is
that's where this season seems to be
going and um you know I I think it was
interesting this morning I think Bill
said in his press conference I might not
have this quote exactly right but I
think you said something along the lines
of like the Raiders have five of the top
players in the league at their positions
which which is probably true it was
almost like so what are you saying about
yourself by just bringing that up on
your own yeah and are you pointing the
finger somewhere else even though you're
the one who had control over all of this
you know it's just I don't know it's
just a weird weird deal there now yeah
that the Raiders have guys at their
position then I would asked Bill how
many players do you have at their
position that they're the best in the
league and I don't know if he'd answer
it but you know I do probably wouldn't
but but mean you look at it and it's
like it's true I mean it's just they
don't they don't have Premier talent and
I think the overriding thing is they're
still operating like it was 10 years ago
like I have like um you know guy I'm
pretty close with who used to be in the
division an NFL executive who said to me
it feels and I think this is the best
way to put it it's like Bill is fighting
the last war of his way you know and
he's kept doing things his way despite
the league continuing to move in
different directions and his way for so
long was supported by some tent poles in
the organization like if you're not as
good on the offensive line Brady will
get rid of the ball a little faster if
you're not as good at receiver Brady
will throw the ball into a little bit of
a tighter window if you can't run the
ball as well you know well Brady can
make up for that in the passing game if
you don't play defense as well Brady
will win shootouts so there's that then
you know you go beyond just the level of
having the greatest player of all time
it's like they built the offensive line
this this year like Dante scaria was
still there and it's really hard to ask
a first year offensive line coach coming
in to perform at that level Dante scaria
turned a college wrestler into a pro
bowl guard you know and he was able to
make things work so many times with less
Talent up there they're still operating
like Dante scari is there when the rest
of the league spends top 10 picks to go
get left tackles you know and so there
are so many of these spots that they're
left short at and it's almost like
they're under the spell well it'll work
itself out doesn't work that way Bill
you got to put good players at those
spots and the best players have good
players at premium positions the way the
Rams won a Super Bowl you know was with
Matt Stafford at quarterback Cooper cup
at receiver Andrew Whitworth at left
tackle Aaron Donald as a pass rusher
Jaylen Ramsey at corner and will'll make
it work everywhere else yeah the
Patriots have never built that way
because they're the greatest player of
all time and they believed in balance
across the roster but it's really really
hard to win that way when you don't have
Tom Brady pulling the trader Albert
Breer the Monday Morning Quarterback all
right let me uh run through some topics
here whose call was it to draft Bryce
young and what was Frank Reich saying at
the press conference yesterday about his
owner I mean ultimately I think it was
David teer call um now I I I do know
that there was pretty strong agreement
that Bryce young was the correct pick at
the time um um and I I can tell you just
having talked to Frank over the last you
know four or five months he really likes
Bryce as a player um there's a lot about
him that um that Frank was enamored with
before the draft and so um do I know
that Frank absolutely
positively loved Bryce young over CJ
stra maybe not but I know he liked Bryce
young quite a bit um but he might have
had to do that because the owner really
loved Bry yeah yeah here's the but I I
would say
I would say I've got a pretty good sense
for some when someone's bsing me I don't
think Frank's bsed me with that like
when I've talked to him about it at
least like I do think he really believes
in Bryce young again doesn't mean didn't
like CJ strout also but you know I do
think he really liked Bryce young um the
idea that t terer is overbearing is not
new um the people who were there last
year felt that way the people in the
front office have felt it he is I and I
think this is a credit to him okay he
runs his football team like he runs his
other businesses like he runs his hedge
fund and I think people who have worked
for him would tell you that it's a high
pressure environment um you know and I
think he's applied that to running his
football team and I think what Frank
said the other day reflects the way a
lot of people have felt working for
David teer and in tepper's defense like
I think the owners that apply their
business principles to running their
football team generally figure out a way
to make it work but doesn't always
happen right right away like you brought
up Robert Craft right it took Robert
Craft a good six years to to to figure
it out and hire Bill bich and and once
they got rolling they were rolling but I
mean he screwed it up with Pete Caroll
now Pete Caroll wasn't Pete Caroll at
that point either wasn't the Pete Carol
of USC or Seattle at that point but it
took Robert Craft like a few years to
figure it out um it's taken other owners
who are really really good Jed York in
San Francisco I think people would tell
you Jed York's done a really good job in
facil ating and enabling guys like John
Lynch and Kyle Shanahan and Prague moroi
and all the guys that that run the show
there I think he would tell you people
would tell you like Jed's done a great
job the last few years he was not
well-liked by Jim Harbaugh you know a
decade ago you know and so I think a lot
of these owners have uh have to go
through a process of figuring it out
when they get in charge and I think this
was you know all of this is part of the
process of David teer getting there and
unfortunately often times there's
collateral damage along the way and it's
not impossible to to Envision a scenario
where this current regime could wind up
being collateral damage help me
understand the deshun Watson situation
with the
Browns yeah I you know
it's they've changed a lot of things
this year um I don't know if people
realize that um they last year it was
really awkward in that they were still
running like the Kevin stefansky offense
that Kevin learned from Gary kubak and
that really worked for their offensive
Personnel before last year um and you
know obviously with the Run game with
Nick chub and Kareem hunt over the years
they produced and Baker Mayfield got a
great year out of it what they found
last year um in you know putting that
offense in for deshun Watson is that it
didn't really work for Watson and this
is something Bill O'Brien went through
in Houston too with Watson in that he
needs to be able to see the field and
he's better out of the shotgun and you
have to involve him in the running game
game and so you know there was a process
this year of getting him through that
and saying okay we're going to build
this offense for you we're going to
retrofit the Shanahan offense for you
they've gone through that now and you
know like I think in that game against
Tennessee they really felt like they hit
on something like they they harped to
him in the building that week completion
driven take the layups just keep the
just keep us on schedule keep the ball
moving and um you know they got to a
point where they felt really good and
then the injury sends it sideways and it
feels like everything has been a little
sideways since he got there even when it
feels like that breakthrough was coming
and I know people internally felt like
that breakthrough was there in the
Tennessee game yeah but it was medically
cleared though Albert and that's the
thing and that's what I'm saying the
injury thing sort of sent that sideways
where it's like okay he's medal
medically cleared and this is a tough
thing because the two words pain
tolerance
Dan
that's like I've always felt like that's
a that that's that's a term that's
always been tough for players to swallow
but that's sort of what it was is like
can you get out there and function based
on the amount of pain that you're going
to be going through and players hate
coaches using that term because it calls
into to question their toughness when
the truth oftentimes is you're in too
much pain to function where you can help
the team right and that's sort of where
deshun Watson was where on that Friday
he could barely lift his arm above his
shoulder come back Saturday okay he
looks okay we think he's going to be
able to play and then on Sunday it's not
where it was so it's going to be very
interesting seeing where they come out
of their bye you know today is obviously
an important day because it's the first
day of practice towards that but you
know they really felt like they hit on
something on that Tennessee in that
Tennessee game that was gonna sort of
straighten out DeShaun Watt and get to
get to Shawn Watson where they
envisioned him being when they gave up
all that draft Capital to go and get him
a year and a half ago
and um you know now they've got what I
think they hope is a speed bump but you
know based on the evidence that we have
right now you'd have to be concerned
like all right like that was one good
week is it going to be more than that
all right quickly let me hit on this uh
if you're uh will teams call the Raiders
about Devonte Adams will teams call the
Vikings about Kirk
Cousins yes and yes um I don't think
either gets moved for separate reasons
um Kirk Cousins I think it's more they
have done a lot of things in Minnesota
with their veterans they've done such a
nice job of keeping veterans happy as
they've retooled the roster like you
don't hear you know you don't you don't
hear Dalvin cook or or mik or or uh or
or Kendricks or you know any of the guys
that have left there over the last year
like saying bad things about that place
Patrick Peterson they've managed a lot
of these guys where they've had to
retool the roster and they Harrison
Smith accepted a pay cut so a lot of
guys have sort of swallowed it and I
think it would be tough for Kevin
oconnell to go back to the team and say
okay now Nick Mullins is your starter or
okay now jiren Hall a rookie fifth round
pick is your starter so I think that's
why they and I also not sure that they
would be able to get enough for kurk
cousins to make it worth it um Devonte
Adams is I I mean playing and simple
they need to win there like and they
need every they it's all hands- on Deck
there right now they need to win and
they need to give the players in that
locker room some proof of concept that
what they're doing is right so I think
in both those situations those guys
stick with those teams the team I would
really watch as far as a potential sell
as we get closer to the trade deadline
could be Denver um you know I just think
looking at where they're at Sea pton in
Shawn Payton um inherited a lot of that
roster they were listening on Jerry Judy
they were listening on court courtand
Sutton back in the spring would a team
give up a one for Judy would a give team
give up a two for Sutton would they L
with teams would would the de Broncos
listen on Garrett BS and if they put
themselves out there on a as a seller is
somebody GNA come try to get Patrick
ceran I I just I think Denver is the
team that's sort of in there and I look
at them and say that's the team you know
that if there's a team that might be
selling off some parts that isn't happy
with where it's at that wants to go a
little bit of reset Denver would be the
one with with Carolina maybe being
another one laying out there in the
weeds like I'm sure they're going to get
calls on Brian Burns as well good to
talk to you as always Albert thank you
absolutely thanks Dan Albert Breer the
Monday Morning Quarterback and keep in
mind what Denver gave up to Seattle to
get Russell Wilson so they need to sort
of restock all those draft picks they
gave up